[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Well, welcome everybody.
And thanks for joining us for
"Behind the div's," a look at
FInd Your Way to Oz, one of
the new Chrome experiments
built by Unit9.
My name is Pete LePage.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Chrome team.
And today, I'm joined by some
of the guys who built Find
Your Way to Oz from
the Unit9 team.
To my left, I've got
Anrick Bregman.
To his left, I've got
Yates Buckley.
And then, Silvio Paganini, who's
going to show us some of
the cool tech stuff.
If you haven't played with Find
Your Way to Oz, if we
could maybe put that URL
up on screen right now.
It's FindYourWayToOz.com.
And really cool Chrome
experiment.
Really awesome way to go see a
little bit about the movie, to
try and go do some really
neat things.
Why don't you guys tell us a
little bit about some of the
things that users can do when
playing around on the site?
And then, we'll talk about
how we built--
how you guys--
built some of these things.
ANRICK BREGMAN: Sure.
The beginning of the project
was really trying to figure
out, how could we tell a story
about this film without
telling the same story
as the film?
Or more, how we could make an
interactive experience that
leads you to the film?
And so very quickly, we began
to focus on the circus and
also, the storm scenes, which
were part of the film.
We watched the film, and we felt
really attracted to those
two sections in the
film experience.
And we felt, wow, there's a lot
of stuff that you can do
there that'll be fun
interactively.
And so focusing on the
circus, first of
all, felt very natural.
Very quickly, we became attached
to this line called
Find Your Way to Oz, which
became the main site URL
eventually.
And that's really the mission
for the user online.
It's every step of the way,
everything that you do, takes
you one step closer to the
world of Oz on film.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
ANRICK BREGMAN: And so that
became a really fun
brainstorm.
What can you do in a circus?
What are the things, the
attractions, that you
can have fun with?
And how could we infuse those
attractions with characters
from the film?
The first one would be a classic
character cut-out type
experience, which is
adding your face to
the characters' bodies.
Then we came up with a
whole range of ideas.
But we zeroed in on that.
Then, it was really fun for us
to think about a musical
experience.
And also, that was led
by tech as well.
The web audio just felt like a
really fun, natural thing to
play with So a musical
organ became our next
focus, our next idea.
And then finally, we had an idea
to create a movie type
capture attraction.
And that came from the film.
As seen in the film, where
Oscar, who was making his way
to Oz, has a zoetrope
in one of his tents.
In his main tent.
PETE LEPAGE: I think that was
when we were looking at some
of prototypes.
The zoetrope was one of my
favorite things, just to see
that happen in real time
and get built up.
We're going to talk about some
of the prototypes and that
kind of stuff in a sec.
But Silvio, why don't you pop
over to the computer over
there, if you don't mind,
and just sort of
bring up the demo?
And let's have a look at some
of the things that are going
on within the demo, so that as
we're talking through some of
these things, we can sort of--
YATES BUCKLEY: The
website demo?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah,
the website.
Sorry.
Yes.
YATES BUCKLEY:The website.
Yeah.
The other interesting thing was,
while we were developing
it, we actually came up with
many different prototypes.
And I think the technology
breadth, in terms of the
exploration phase,
was very wide.
But it was funny, because some
of the things we came up with
maybe were kind of like,
too tech for a
circus for that scenario.
They didn't create that
dreamy space.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
Well, what's--
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah.
Here, we're looking at inside
of one of the scenes.
You see, actually, that the
photo booth and some of the--
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So if we go into the
photo booth--
can we get rid of the URL
on screen right now?
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah, so this
is the photo booth capture.
And there's a really nice
transition into a lens change
there, in the 3D engine.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
YATES BUCKLEY: Sorry,
I'm looking--
PETE LEPAGE: So we're looking
at the screen here.
And I know you guys
can't see us.
Unfortunately, there's no camera
on the computer that
we're doing this demo on, so
it makes it a little bit
harder to show this off.
But you can try this
on your own.
Does the music box work for--
would we be able to give
that one a shot?
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah.
You should be able to
work the music box.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
ANRICK BREGMAN: In all of the
interactions that we had, and
all of the attractions, we had
a really nice mix of very
classic asset switches,
hand-painted textures--
[CIRCUS MUSIC PLAYING]
ANRICK BREGMAN: --such as in the
photo booth, and also here
in the music box, hand-painted
character textures, combined
with these WebGL models.
And then, the interface on top,
which is something that
allows you to edit and change
what you're seeing.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So that's actually a good
transition point as we look at
some of these things.
What was building some
of these things like?
Because I remember seeing early
on, we had a whole bunch
of prototypes for some
individual things.
And then we said, OK, well,
we're going to put all these
pieces together.
And Silvio, if you want to come
on back, and we can talk
about some of those things.
What was the process like
to build these out?
What were some of the things
that you guys went through?
I know there's a lot of WebGL
involved in this.
There's a lot of
CSS animations.
There's a whole bunch
of sprite stuff.
What's going on?
How did you build some
of these things?
SILVIO PAGANINI: So basically,
we started prototyping most of
the technology we could
use in Chrome.
And one really interesting
thing to use--
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
Can we pull up Silvio's
desktop?
SILVIO PAGANINI: Yeah, so
one of the first ones
was the card loading.
So it's all a CSS3 transition.
So here, you can see on the
fly all the values for the
WebKit transform.
So as you hover your mouse,
you're just using the 3D
transformations of it.
I could click and see the other
side of it, which is
basically the whole concept
behind the website, was two
sides of Oz.
That was the first one,
[? this live ?] one here.
We actually have another
prototype for 3D.
Want to show some 3D as well?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
SILVIO PAGANINI: So actually,
we can go for the sprite
sheets, maybe, for the
high-DPI devices.
So one thing that was quite a
neat, the experience works for
both the normal screens and
the high-DPI screens.
And one way to do this was to
use the sprite sheets and the
new CSS properties for that.
So my screen's not high-DPI, but
we can't see this, but at
least we can see the whole
story about this.
So we can see the sprite sheets
on my machine here.
[? It's probably ?]
PNG.
You can't see much.
But all the assets are in one
PNG, and then you just control
them on the DOM.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
Cool.
So if we can come back
to us for a sec.
One of the things I think is
really fascinating was how you
guys did think through how to
deal with high-DPI screens, as
well as on non-high-DPI
screens.
What challenges did you face
when thinking about that?
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah, I mean,
I think it's sort of an
infrastructure decision.
A lot of things we had to deal
with technologically became
quickly kind of infrastructure
decisions.
Like, how do we set this up so
we don't have to worry about
it later, and that the creative
team can just work
along and not have any bad
surprises later on?
So we were always double
thinking what might
go wrong in a way.
And one of them was
the high-DPI.
Which I think tied really well
with the sprite sheets
application, because then you
can just pick the right asset
on the fly and deal with
these kind of problems.
Yeah, so--
PETE LEPAGE: Now, are you
sending high-DPI images only
to devices that deserve
them, and lower to--?
SILVIO PAGANINI: Yes.
So basically, we load for
the normal sprite
sheet for all devices.
And if we detect that there is
a high-DPI device loading the
website, then we load
the new one.
PETE LEPAGE: And how
did you do that?
What was the mechanism
you used?
SILVIO PAGANINI: If you can show
my screen, there's one
[? comment ?] we found out,
which is window dot aspect
ratio device pixel ratio.
And then these would
show the high--
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
SILVIO PAGANINI: --which
screen--
PETE LEPAGE: So you
can go through.
OK.
SILVIO PAGANINI: So on a
high-DPI screen, it'll show
here 2 as a result.
And on my screen, of course,
it's showing 1 because I don't
have the high-DPI one.
So that's a trick that I used.
PETE LEPAGE: Now were you
checking for the straight up
value of 2?
Or were you checking
for greater than 1?
SILVIO PAGANINI:
Greater than 1.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
And that's the right
way to go.
I was dealing with one project
a couple of months ago.
And they had assumed that the
device pixel ratio value would
always be a whole number.
And it was like 1.4 or 1.3.
So when they were doing some
math on it, it was
coming down to 1.
And everything just
looked wrong.
We were trying to figure
out what was going on.
And as it turns out, that
was the reason.
So you want to definitely make
sure when you're looking at
that number, be aware, it
might not be 2 or 1.
It might be somewhere
in between.
It might even be higher.
At some point, hopefully we'll
get even higher DPI displays.
SILVIO PAGANINI: At
some point, yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
That would be really
kind of cool.
Cool.
YATES BUCKLEY: I think the thing
I really wanted to show
also-- it kind of falls in with
this idea of the DPI and
trying to handle problems.
If you could throw
the first video.
If you could launch that.
Basically, a lot of the site in
it used a control panel to
control settings that were
critical to the experience.
[GUSTING WINDS]
YATES BUCKLEY: And it
was kind of bizarre.
The team was a very big
team, actually.
[INAUDIBLE].
So it was very difficult with
certain problems you run into
to get everybody to agree on
what's really going on, what
really needs to be done.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
YATES BUCKLEY: Is that
video up now?
PETE LEPAGE: It just
finished running.
So that's--
YATES BUCKLEY: Sorry.
The video is the first one?
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
And after we do that, one
thing I do want mention.
For people who are watching
this live, we do have a
moderator queue that you
can ask questions at.
So Paul, when you get a sec, if
we could put the moderator
link up for the questions.
Please post your questions
there, so that we can try and
answer some of your questions
live as we go today.
We've got a computer up here
so that I can see what the
questions coming in are, and
we can go from there.
So it looked like--.
YATES BUCKLEY: So basically, the
story is that to make this
kind of content with a bigger
team, you need to have sort of
a middle ground.
You need to create a middle
ground, which you can use to
tweak values or not and agree
together whether that
particular saturation, or how
strong one particular effect
or another can work together.
Because every part of the team
doesn't necessarily have the
whole picture.
So it was always kind of
iterating through things.
And for everything we created,
we'd create an interface for
it, a live interface that people
could try changing.
So I encourage people--
I think one of the most fun
aspects of the site is if you
look at the beginning of the
HTML5 Rocks site, is if you
call this site with the bug
equals on and then press
Control I, I think it is, and
then you'll have a drop-down
with all the controls
[INAUDIBLE]
PETE LEPAGE: Oh cool.
YATES BUCKLEY: --being
exposed.
It's sort of fun to discover
what's been--
ANRICK BREGMAN: Well, it was
amazing for the team, because
we had a lot of distance
between everybody.
Not just geographically, but
also in terms of, let's say,
the expertise that
everybody has.
So a WebGL 3D team might not
necessarily get too involved
with the hand-painted skies
that we were making.
And for that to be a kind of
feedback loop between those
teams constantly, trying to
adjust and perfect things,
kind of didn't make sense.
It felt better for everybody to
be able to get their part
of the whole piece perfect first
before integrating it
with the greater project.
So it was a very smart way to
give everybody control of what
they were making and to share
very quickly the kind of
perfect settings from
everybody's perspective.
And then in the end, there's a
process of choosing one of the
several options.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
ANRICK BREGMAN: But that makes
it a fun process rather than a
very stressful one.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
And by being able to give
everybody that opportunity to
play and experiment on their
own, they really have that,
like, I can feel how my
value's going in.
And then when we talk about it
as a team, we can really--
YATES BUCKLEY: Exaclty.
ANRICK BREGMAN: And most
importantly, you can be wrong.
Because it's obviously very
frustrating if you say, oh,
let's make it a 2, and then
it's actually 2 point--
oh, no, no.
Let's make it 2.5.
Oh no.
Actually, let's make it 1.5.
That becomes very stressful if
that loop goes through the
whole team and it takes
people's time.
If it's you yourself,
you can experiment.
You can play.
You can go wrong.
You can go back.
But only when you're
comfortable, you can share.
So that's a detail.
It just makes sense.
It just makes it easier and more
fun for the whole team.
PETE LEPAGE: Speaking of the
team, how big was the team who
worked on this?
YATES BUCKLEY: It
was quite big.
I mean--
SILVIO PAGANINI: Yeah, we
got probably 30 people.
YATES BUCKLEY: We had this Skype
chat open with, it was
like, maybe about 12 people
on it at any one time.
And it's been going
on for months.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, wow.
SILVIO PAGANINI: Yeah, we
have different chats.
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah.
We have different
chats as well.
But there's one main one,
which is the main.
There's a lot of people and a
lot of specialists that are
doing very particular work that
nobody else understands.
So it's like--
PETE LEPAGE: And you guys were
also really distributed as
well, weren't you?
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: So where was--
YATES BUCKLEY: So the back-end
team is in Poland.
SILVIO PAGANINI: Yeah.
We have the back-end
team in Poland--
YATES BUCKLEY: 3D in Florence.
SILVIO PAGANINI: --which
was very--
and doing back-end and mobile.
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah.
Back-end and mobile.
SILVIO PAGANINI: And then we
have the guys in Florence that
are doing the 3D.
PETE LEPAGE: Wow.
SILVIO PAGANINI: We
had the guys in
Stockholm doing the designs.
We had the guy in Barcelona.
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah.
SILVIO PAGANINI: The
team in London.
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah.
I think that's the main--
SILVIO PAGANINI: That's
the main thing.
Yeah.
ANRICK BREGMAN: And there
were a few other extra
bits here and there.
It's sort of a lot of
specialists who come on board
for a certain time, then
somebody else takes over, and
then the first team comes
back and makes changes.
And it's a really nice back
and forth that way.
But everybody was very engaged
in a way that distance starts
to fall away when people are
really passionate about what
they're making.
And when it seems to work, when
you sort of feel like
there's constantly progress,
everyone becomes very engaged
in spite of the distance.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Yeah.
Beyond some of the CSS Sprite
things, let's sort of pop over
to talk about some of
the WebGL stuff.
Because this is such a beautiful
WebGL experience.
Right?
Like it really does take full
advantage of the GPU to just
create real moving stuff.
I think when we were talking
earlier Anrick, you were
talking about how just all of
the scenes are hand painted.
And being able to get that
stuff in is just
such an art form now.
And going to there is
pretty phenomenal.
So why don't talk a little bit
about how that process worked.
And I think we talked earlier
about maybe doing a--
let's have a look at this one.
If we can switch to the laptop
up here for a sec.
So do you want to tell
us what this is?
SILVIO PAGANINI: Yeah.
So basically, that was one of
the early prototypes we'd done
with the whole elements of the
scene plugged in from the 3D.
And that was just to see how the
camera movement would be
on the environment, while
deciding and see how many
objects it would load on real
time for the WebGL to handle.
So it was one of the first and
most effective ways to see how
WebGL was going to perform
in every single machine.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah.
Then we went through
iterations.
We had to establish a
pipeline for the 3D.
That was a very early critical
aspect to the whole project,
because the particular--
basically, it's still early
days in some of these
technologies.
And so setting up a good
pipeline for WebGL, it's
something we hadn't
really dealt with
at this scale before.
And so, it was a bit of
tooling that went on
beforehand.
We had to convert some tools we
had before to try to figure
out how to support things
like bones animations,
this kind of stuff.
PETE LEPAGE: Now what are
bones animations?
YATES BUCKLEY: It means that
rather than animating every
point, say, of a joint that's
animated, you can animate the
angle basically-- the change
in angle of one item.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, OK.
YATES BUCKLEY: So basically,
it saves a lot of space.
And it also allows you a more
intuitive control of the scene
in that sense.
And you'll see that in the
balloon at the end.
The balloon is bending
in a way.
It goes through the wind.
That's run by this
bone system, that
isn't by default supported.
It's something that
we had to create.
And then on HTML5 Rocks site,
we've sort of focused on--
wind was a very important theme
of the whole site, so we
focused on what we did to
create the wind effect.
And if you go to HTML5 Rock's
demo site, there was a number
of prototypes, one of them we're
showing here, in which
you see how this noise
field is generating
this kind of mutation--
it's actually a vertex shader
that we're changing the
position of and modifying.
And again, you have all these
settings open again, so that
we can figure out the detail.
And the particles floating
around, as well, are affected
by the same kind of flowing
field beneath it.
SILVIO PAGANINI: Maybe just
show this thing here.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
If we could just pop over to
the screen for one sec.
YATES BUCKLEY: Oh, OK.
I thought it was on screen.
Yeah, I think that is the demo
from the HTML5 Rocks--
SILVIO PAGANINI: Yeah, that's
the complete demo.
YATES BUCKLEY: That's
And we encourage
to look at it.
It's not too complex
of a scene.
And I think it's quite fun,
actually, because you've got
everything in it and
all the controls.
SILVIO PAGANINI: Yeah.
You can play around with the
controls the same way you play
with the website.
So, we tried to do a seamless
transition for everyone to
understand the tools we're using
throughout the whole
website development.
PETE LEPAGE: So what were the
tools you were using?
Like, I'm not a WebGL
kind of guy.
I never got into it.
And it sort of often
went over my head.
So how did you start?
What was the process
for building this?
YATES BUCKLEY: What
we needed to do.
This pipeline basically means,
OK, we had to find out in the
very early days what kind of
creative input could we get to
create the 3D world and
the WebGL world.
So we actually went back and
tried to convert a tool that
we had created before.
It was a Flash-based tool.
And we converted that to
be able to support
the converting models.
Basically, animations and models
from Maya, then were--
you could just go through it and
convert them into a scene.
But it had to be read in a
particular way, et cetera.
But once we did that, then it
was a matter of honing the
different effects.
So I think in a way, we were
in parallel working on
optimizing a scene, and the
shaders that we had to--
so, figuring out different
shaders for very particular
effects, whether it's a
particularl lighting effect,
or a particular like the god
rays, or we have a nice demo
for the lighting.
I don't know if you could
actually show that.
Do you have that one?
OK.
SILVIO PAGANINI: No.
YATES BUCKLEY: No, OK.
Anyhow, and including one of
the shaders for the storm
sequence, which is this sort of
twirling tornado, which--
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
If we could pull up
that for one sec--
YATES BUCKLEY: --has a strange
history to it kind
of thing, in a way.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Do you want to tell us a
little bit about that?
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah.
We went through many iterations
of different models
to try-- oh, gosh.
I lost it.
ANRICK BREGMAN: It was
initially a nice
idea to do a storm.
And we felt very drawn
to the storm.
And it became very quickly a
case of, OK, so how on Earth
are we going to make
this exciting,
intense, but also beautiful?
And how are we going to
make it interactive?
It was a big challenge.
Plus, in the browser
dynamically
rendered as you go.
And so after a few interesting
demos and experiments, we
ended up with a shader
approach.
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah,
so it was all this.
And I'm also studying
neuroscience,
actually, in parallel.
And we've been working on some
games for getting-- basically,
the idea is that people could
help us trace connectivity
between brain cells.
And as part of that research--
which is not live yet, but I'd
encourage people if they're
interested to go to
brainflight.org and register
to keep updated on it--
one of the things we did is we
created a viewer that shows
the inside a brain
cell, basically.
You could navigate
through that.
We have a clip of it
that we could show.
PETE LEPAGE: That's the brain?
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
YATES BUCKLEY: So this is like
very, very, very small.
What you're looking through,
it's something like, I think
it's about 40 or 50 nanometers,
which is very,
very small.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, wow.
YATES BUCKLEY: And you're going
through a connection
between one brain cell
and another.
And the problem is that there's
so many of them, it's
not obvious how we're going to
get the manpower to actually
trace the connections.
This is why the idea is maybe
make a game or something, get
people to help us.
But we started from
that, and we tried
adding a twist, actually.
Because it looked a little
bit like a tornado.
It looked like the funnel
of a tornado.
So we added a transformation,
like a twist to it, and added
some noise to it.
And something came out that
was very tornado-like.
So what then we just had to
figure out is how to give it
this wispy kind of
effect on it.
And that was done just basically
by evaluating it
multiple times and mixing
these together.
And then once you made that
tornado, which we showed
earlier in terms of that kind
of-- we then had to get it
inside the scene.
And then, you could probably,
if you can, switch to this
machine here, we have a
picture of the tornado
overlapped with the Tokyo
Shibuya background that we
grabbed from somewhere.
So here, you see the tornado
just kind of on top of the
scene in the background.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
YATES BUCKLEY: And to create the
storm sequence, basically,
there are many layers
like this.
There is a background, and there
are, like, drops on the
front screen.
SILVIO PAGANINI: Some clouds.
YATES BUCKLEY: There's clouds.
And they're all different
techniques, actually.
So the clouds are a
particle-based system.
The clouds are low-hanging.
While the tornadoes
is custom shader.
The balloon is a layer that's
just for the balloon.
It's very complicated to handle
the balloon correctly
when it goes into the tornado,
for example.
Or for example, at one point,
we had to give the feeling
that you're being sucked
up into the
whirlwind of the tornado.
And we couldn't do that because
of the way the scene
was structured.
So what we had do was rotate the
world around the camera,
rather than you rotate
the camera.
Because a lot of the objects
we had were flat.
So the background rotates at a
certain point, and it gives
you that feeling of you being
taken up into this space.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
ANRICK BREGMAN: It's a very
nice mix of very new
techniques and very classic
techniques, very classic
filmmaking techniques.
Lighting and matte paintings in
the background, layered up
with this very interesting
custom shading.
And what I find amazing,
especially, is how, for
example, the classic
matte painting
mixes with the shading.
It's something that's quite
surprising, because the
shaders are always changing.
And so the background matte
painting is static, but the
shader is constantly changing
the visual.
PETE LEPAGE: That's
really cool.
Well, there's a couple of
questions up in the moderator
queue that I want to take
a look at and get
your opinion on.
So the first question is
from somebody in Italy.
And they want to know, do you
think that WebGL is going to
affect a lot of the
future of the web?
SILVIO PAGANINI: Yes,
definitely.
YATES BUCKLEY: I have
an opinion.
Yeah, go ahead.
SILVIO PAGANINI: I think so.
I mean, as long as Chrome and
the other browsers are trying
to push this WebGL.
The performance that I can
get here is amazing.
Like the tornado scene, for
example, is the lightest scene
we have on our website.
So if you enter the website,
the first carnival scene is
pretty heavy.
My machine's really struggling
to keep up.
And the tornado itself is
a main shader thing.
And it's really heavy.
You don't see any of the--
the fan is running crazy.
So I do think in the near
future, the WebGL is going to
be a nice thing to do.
YATES BUCKLEY: I mean, I think
the thing that's the
interesting story is the
relationship between the
high-DPI devices and 3D tech.
Because when you're making game
design, for example, if
you make it in 3D, then
you don't have to
worry about this issue.
And you don't have to worry
about the aspect ratio of the
phone so much or the device,
because you can just to
reposition the camera in one way
or another and manage to
make an experience that people
feel natural with.
And I think that's a big driver
towards that kind of
technology [? and doctrine. ?]
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Cool.
Yeah, well, somebody from Zurich
wants to know, what was
the most difficult part?
Was there a point where you
had to change the plan in
order to comply with the
technical possibilities?
I think I know the
answer to this.
But I'll let you
guys sort of--
YATES BUCKLEY: There
were many parts.
It was full of decisions.
ANRICK BREGMAN: It was
a rollercoaster ride.
It was absolutely a
rollercoaster ride.
PETE LEPAGE: And I think that's
part of the point of a
Chrome experiment.
With a Chrome experiment,
you're pushing the web.
You're doing things that have
never been done before.
You're taking the browser
to its limit.
And there are always going to
be those places where you're
like, and we just fell
over the edge.
Whoops.
ANRICK BREGMAN: You
got to go back.
PETE LEPAGE: You got to pull
back a little, or maybe
rethink, or sometimes,
hopefully, you can get a
browser bug fixed.
ANRICK BREGMAN: I think the
storm was probably the
trickiest to realize.
We were pretty ambitious about
making a storm that felt as
beautiful and intense as
the one in the film.
Obviously, that story
is different.
But we wanted it to live
up to the film.
And I think there were a few
points where we thought, well,
we're not going to manage.
And I can imagine Yates at home
on the weekend working on
brainflight.org and having a
kind of epiphany moment going,
wait a minute.
This mouse brain looks
just like a storm.
And he came into the office and
said, OK, whatever you're
doing with the storm, stop it.
It's not going to work.
We're going in a different
direction.
So that was a key moment, I
think, where we turned the
storm around.
And there was a vision of
something that didn't--
well, it looked like
a mouse brain.
But we were going to
make it a storm.
And we had a mission,
and it worked out.
It was a big risk, but
it worked out.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
Well, we've got another
question here
from someone who wants--
I guess they were looking at the
optimization and wanted to
know why you didn't go with the
WebP image format instead
of PNG, since WebP can be up
to almost 25%, 26% smaller.
SILVIO PAGANINI: The only reason
I didn't use it is
because we did not have a fall
back on the CSS for the
[INAUDIBLE] images.
One other thing we did see for
the optimizations is, if you
look at the timeline on Chrome,
every time I apply a
style to a DOM element, you're
at peak of memory usage.
So if you don't have an
immediate fall back on CSS for
all the images, you [? inject ?]
the CSS for the
image on the element.
So this would be like a
massive problem for
performances.
So that's the main reason.
Because this runs in other
browsers as well, so we try to
make it as--
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
Yeah.
I think that's one ask that
I would have for other web
developers out there, is demand
WebP support out of
your browser.
Right?
Whether it's Firefox,
whether it's
Opera, IE, Safari, whatever.
We need more people
to support this.
And we need the other browser
vendors to step up.
And as web developers, I think
it's our job to go and say to
the web browser vendors,
we want this.
Give it to us.
SILVIO PAGANINI: Even though
they don't give us, at least
the fall back [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Or give us a good way to be
able to have a fall back.
Something to that effect.
Absolutely.
So that's the end of the
questions that up out there
that people have posted.
I'll leave that list
up for a second.
But I just want to talk a little
bit about you guys.
So you guys are Unit9.
You do projects like this.
Do you want to tell a little bit
more about Unit9, some fun
things you guys do?
YATES BUCKLEY: This is probably
the peak of the
excitement in terms
of the jobs we do.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
YATES BUCKLEY: I mean, to have
the client come in and say, we
want you to make an experiment
for us, is just like
a dream come true.
It's like, OK, we're going to
go totally crazy here and do
everything we never dared
do in other situations.
But yeah, we do this kind of
thing and these kind of jobs.
And yeah, I've have been
doing it for a while.
We like to work in
a very open way.
You can find a full credit list
of everybody that worked
on this job, every name.
If you go to the site,
it's on there.
We're very open about other
collaborations.
This job wouldn't have been
possible without support from
another other key partners
in this job.
And so yeah.
We believe in that video game
model, where you just get the
best people together and
do the best job.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
What's the website
for you guys?
YATES BUCKLEY: Unit9.com.
PETE LEPAGE: Unit9.com So nice
and easy to remember.
One of the things that I also
want to call out is you guys
wrote a phenomenal HTML5
Rocks tutorial--
well, I guess it's more
of a case study.
But it went through how you
built a lot of these things.
There's great code samples.
There's a couple of things that
people can go in and play
with, diving deep into
this kind of stuff.
So definitely check that out.
It's up on html5rocks.com.
You can go see that there.
YATES BUCKLEY: Yeah.
It's been very successful
as well.
I really recommend it.
We made an effort to pick out
and make prototypes that you
can chew on, so that you don't
have to get the whole code
base, and still can
have some fun.
SILVIO PAGANINI: Yeah, if you
have a look on Google Code,
there's the full code for
everything as well.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, phenomenal.
Oh, cool.
SILVIO PAGANINI: And the we have
the prototype codes for
everything there as well.
So just go and--
YATES BUCKLEY: Plenty
to look at.
PETE LEPAGE: So if somebody were
to pull that down, could
they just upload it to their own
little server and get it
running reasonably well?
All right.
SILVIO PAGANINI: Yeah.
The whole website's just
coded in CoffeeScript.
So also, there's a Cakefile
which compiles
the whole thing up.
PETE LEPAGE: Sweet.
All right.
And you're hosting
it on App Engine?
SILVIO PAGANINI: App
Engine, yes.
YATES BUCKLEY: The App
Engine code is not
currently up there.
I think for security reasons,
we're sort of waiting on that.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, there's
some of the
back-end stuff is--
YATES BUCKLEY: But otherwise,
yeah, everything's there.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Well, I think that's about all
we have time for today.
We're just at about 30
minutes, 35 minutes.
I want to thank you guys
for coming in.
It was a really great
opportunity to learn a little
bit more about this.
I hope you guys watching live
learned something new and
enjoyed it.
Definitely go check the site out
at findyourwaytooz.com It
also works-- we didn't dive into
this at all today, but
the mobile experience
is pretty slick.
I can pull it up on a phone or
tablet, whether it's an iPad
or whether it's a Nexus device,
an Android device.
So definitely go
check that out.
You can try it in Chrome
for Android.
You can try it in a couple
other things.
So thank you, gentlemen.
And thank you guys
for joining us.
I hope you enjoyed it.
And we'll talk to
you real soon.
Bye bye.
Thank you.